on appelle ça la beauté du jeu mais même
s'il est beau il est compliqué parce que
le sour comme vous dites ici c'est comme
la vie je penseon vra coup à jouer la
saison prochaine
jeien tu es la bonne nouvelle c'est que
tu as de option option
numéro
plus
amux notre pays a décidé de créer son
équipe encore humation ça va changer je
vais nous trouver un nouveau
[Musique]
coach
confiance ok confiance ça suffit me
touche pas la confiance
est la seule chose que je veux c'est
qu'on marque un but un se
but
je peux pas bosser avec ces gens je peux
pas les aider on t'a pas envoyé sur
cette île pour aider cette équipe on l'a
fait pour t'aider toi
c'estadh on peut dire qu'on fait des
progrs seigneur merci de nous avoir
envoyé monsieur Ren nous nous sommes
beaucoup attachés à lui un peu comme
lorsqu'on trouve un enfant blanc perdu
dans un centre commercial et qu'on lui
indique le chemin à
suivre